[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد
عن رغبته في اسرائيل تويتر حتى اثار هذا
الاعلان مخاوف الغربيه عده من المتغيرات
التي تطرا على المنصه فقد اعرب البيت
الابيض عن قلقه من قوه تاثير وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي نعتبر ان هذه المنصات
في حاجه لان تخضع للحساب خشيه ان تتحول
اداه للتضليل كما اعلن حينها البيت الابيض
مواصله العمل من اجل الغاء القانون 230
لذي يحمي شركه الانترنت من المحاسبه على
المحتوى الذي ينشره المستخدمون ويدعم
تشديد اجراءات الشفافيه ومكافحه الاحتكار
على شركه التكنولوجيا المخاوف كانت كبيره
في اوروبا ايضا بموجب قواعد حمايه
البيانات في الاتحاد الاوروبي وقانون
الخدمات الرقميه الجديده يجب على الشركات
التي تخدم مستعملي الوان الاوروبيين
سلبيات معايير صارمه
فيتعلق بالمحتوى الخطير وحمايه الخصوصيه
وشفافيه خوارزميهم ولكن هناك قلق في
بروكسل من ان موقف ماسك التحرري لحريه
التعبير وترده موظفي تويتر سيقوض الجهود
المبذوله للقضاء على الدعايات وخطاب
الكراهيه والمضايقه
[موسيقى]
هناك شهاده الموضوع مع ضيوفنا منه
اورلاندو اوتوم حرب رايس وتحالف الامريكيه
شرقي الديمقراطيه اهلا بك ومن القاهره
احمد الشيخ مستشار
البريطانيه للاستشارات اهلا بكم ضيوف
الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من القاهره معك
يا استاذ احمد قبل الحديث عن موضوع
التضليل بخصوص البيانات الشخصيه
في هذا الاطار بصفه عامه هل حضرتك ترى
منطق في طريقه اداره الى الماسك لتويتر
الجديد ليست تويتر جديد ولكن الاداره
الجديده هل ترى منطق معين تتبعه يمكن ان
تفهم به شيء
انا ارى فيه منطقا فعلا وهو المنطق
الموسكي ممكن نسميه بهذا الشكل علشان نفهم
هي دي طريقه ال الماسك في الاداره ليست
اداره تويتر وحده ولكن اداره كل شيء له
الماسك رجل معروف بيه الفرقعات الاعلاميه
والمشروعات الجريئه التي تنجح احيانا
وتخفق احيانا اخرى علشان نفهم اللي بيحميك
بيعمله الماسك والقرارات التي يتخذها بين
حين واخر لازم نفهم شخصيه له الماسك
وادارته ليه اا يعني شركاتها المختلفه
وماذا يريد الى الماسك من تويتر هو له
الماسك لم يشتري تويتر لكي يحوله الى منصه
لحريه التعبير كما يقول لا هو اشترت تويتر
حتى السؤال لا نعلم ان كان يريد شيء همم
حتى في مواضيع تتعلق بطريقه اداره تويتر
يقول اليوم شيء ويعود عنه بعد فتره وجيزه
هو في الاساس هل يريد شيء من تويتر
ولو احنا حبينا نختصر يعني اهداف ايلين
ماسك من شراء تويتر ومن اداراته تويتر
فاحنا ممكن نحطهم تحت خانهتين او تحت
فئتين من الاهداف الفئه الاولى هي الفئه
الاقتصاديه هو يريد ان يحقق مكاسب
اقتصاديه كبرى وسينجح في ذلك ويريد ايضا
الفئه الاخرى بقى هي الاهداف السياسيه لان
تويتر هو منصه اداره الراي العام وسيله
اداره الراي العام الاقوى في العالم
وبالتالي فان له الماسك يريد ان يحقق
مكاسب اقتصاديه وسياسيه الى الماسك يتوقع
خبر سعيدا في يوم 17 واحد على سبيل المثال
ماذا سيحدث يوم 17 واحد 2023 لو لو استمر
الحاله على ما هو عليه سيصبح المغرد الاول
في العالم وده كان واحد من احد واحد من
اهداف اللي كان عايز عشانها يشتري تويتر
هو كان منزعج اوباما هو المغرد الاول
برصيد 13
لو استمر معدل جاذب لهم ماسك ليه
المتابعين الجدد بفضل ما يفعله حاليا
سيحدث يوم الاولى
فيصبح المغرد الاول في العالم اذا بحسب
قراءتك هناك همم ماليه وهناك حسابات
سياسيه استاذ توم ان كانت هذه الحسابات
السياسيه قائمه فعلا للعلماس همم يبدو بان
طريقه تعامله مع المنصه همم بالعكس هي
ستدفعه ليواجه انتقادات من سياسيين اليوم
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك
انتقادات شديده لانوس همم له اداراته لي
همم تويتر واكثر من ذلك يعتبرونه مظلل في
ما يخص البيانات الشخصيه
اولا مرحبا لك وللجميع احمد وللمشاهدين
عمليه التضليل اذا هنالك من عمل
الذي تطلق الصواريخ الى الفضاء والاقمار
الصناعيه والدوله الامريكيه شريكه بهذه
بهذه التكنولوجيا معه
فلماذا يوافقون على هذه الاطلاقات لانه
على الفضاء عنده اكثر من حوالي 2000 قمر
اصطناعي وربما سيصل الى 30000 قمر اصطناعي
يربط العالم كله ببعضه وطبعا الحكومه
الامريكيه تشارك معه ليس هنالك من اي
تضليل ولكن نسبه المستعملين اليوم تويتر
بالولايات المتحده 60% من الحزب
الديمقراطي اليسارى و30% من الحزب
الجمهوري اي متى بدات المشكله بالفعل منذ
سنتين بالالف 2020 قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه بشهر على الضبط عندما
انفضحت قضيه
عنتر بايدن نجل الرئيس الحالي الجو بايدن
بعمليه الكمبيوتر وكانت هنالك وسيله
اعلاميه نيويورك بوس ونشرتها وتويتر حاولت
ان تخفيه هذه القضيه وقام بعد ذلك اكثر من
50 مسؤول ثابت في المخابرات الامريكيه
بعثوا برساله للتوضيح بان هذا الكمبيوتر
هذا جهاز الكمبيوتر هذا مدلل من ال- ال-
الروش وليست وليست واقع عند دائم فضحت
العمليه بعد سنتين وتبين ان المخابرات
الامريكيه تلاحق نزل الرئيس وان بالفعل
تويتر هي التي سمعت هذه الاخبار وانا
اتصور بان السيد همم الى مصر هو انسان
مواطن عادي يحاول ان يرجع الحقيقه الى
مصدرها والواقع الى الدستور الامريكي وهو
حوريه
يعني استاذ توم هل هو كذلك
احمد همم مبدئيا هل هو منقذ هذه المنصه
وفي جزء اخر هل ظننا ام لا هل هذه المخاوف
لديها او همم لهذه المخاوف اساس من الصحه
واحد من المتسببين في التضليل هو اللي كان
نشر بعض السيناريوهات القائمه على نظريات
المؤامره فيما يتعلق بزوج نانسي فلوسي ثم
حذف التغريده عندما تعرض لي الاحراج هو
نفسه اللي لسه مش عارف لحد دلوقت يحط
معايير لتجميد سوري لا تفعيل الحسابات
المجمده مش عارفين الحسابات اللي بتعود
بتعود على اي اساس وهل اا دونالد ترامب
هيعود فعلا ولا هناك حسابات سياسيه
واقتصاديه تؤجل عودته طبعا له الماسك
يتمنى عوده همم دونالد ترامب ولكن على
فكره الموضوع
اقوى منهم هم الاثنين بسبب تحالفات سياسيه
واقتصاديه اخرى لا طبعا يعني وجود ماسك
لان يحول همم تويتر الى ساحه او واحه ال-
حريه التعبير والمصداقيه لا بالعكس هو
الان متورط في التضليل ومتورط ايضا يعني
هو كما يطلق صواريخ الى الفضاء هو عنده
افراد في اطلاق ال- همم التغريدات يعني في
يوم واحد الراجل بيكتب 75 تغريده هل هل ده
منطقي فيه حد بيكتب 75% يوم واحد كان هل
ترى منطقا لها سبب ان سؤالي الاول كان هل
ترى منطق في اداره ايلون ماسك للمنصه وفي
تعمله معها ولكن همم تحدثت عن انه لا يضلل
فقط فيما يخص البيانات بل انه كذلك سيد
طعم كما يقول ضيفي ظل حتى من خلال
تغريداته هو يطرح افكار تحمل الكثير من
المغلقه هو يضلل»
انا بتصور لكن
القوانين الامريكيه بالنسبه لهذه المنصات
اخر قرار كان اما مشروع امريكي كان سنتر
96 يعني كان بعد الانترنت ببداها ومنذ ذلك
الوقت اليوم الكونجرس الامريكي لم يشرع اي
شيء جديد بعهد الرئيس السابق ترامب حاولوا
تشريع ولكن اليسار الاميركي الديمقراطيين
فاتوا بتهمه التواطؤ مع روسيه وثلاث سنوات
معارك هو بهذا بهذا الملف اليوم يجب على
المشرعين ان بالفعل ان يكونوا ويشرعوا هذه
المنصات من جوجل للفيسبوك حتى
لا تويتر ليكون عندنا مصدر يعني نؤمن به
كشعب امريكي
فقط
بانو موضوع التشريع موضوع صعب جدا يعني
انسان يفصل حتى المصطلحات حريه التعبير في
حد ذاتها لما نحاول انا وانت والاستاذ
احمد
همم تفسيرها او تقديم تعريف قد نختلف
ثلاثتنا فاست استاذ احمد كيف ترى هذه
النقطه التي اقترحها ضيفي هل هي مشكله
ماسك ام مشكله تشريعات
لا هي مشكله عدم وجود اراده من الجانبين
لتنسيق الموضوع جميع الاطراف مستفيده حتى
الان من هذه الفوضى لهم ماسك مستفيد طبعا
لان في تفاعل كبير بيحصل على تويتر هو
نفسه بيقول انه همم معدل التفاعل على
تويتر وصل الى اعلى معدل هو نفسه بيكسب
270,000 متابع جديد يوميا فهو طبعا هو
اكثر واحد مبسوط في حاله الفوضى وحاله
الجدل الكبيره المحيطه في تويتر همم
الكونجرس الامريكي احنا مش بنطالبه ان هو
همم يقر قوانين جديده لا احنا بنطالبه ان
هو يعني ايه يحاسب له الماسك لانه يستطيع
ان يحاسب الى الماسك كما حسب مارك ذكر من
قبل وماركذكر رغم انه يمتلك ال- يعني هو
رئيس المنصه الاجتماعيه الاقوى في العالم
ولكن له ليس مصابا الافراط في التغريد كما
هي حاله الى ماسك حاليا هو ماركذكر فقط
فيما يتعلق بالشركه ولكن الماده و30 هي
توفر حمايه
للماده ال 230 في من قانون من قانون
الاتصالات الامريكي لديهم يتضرع بها همم
اصحاب شركات التكنولوجيا هي توفر حمايه من
حيث المحتوى ولكنها لا توفر حمايه من حيث
اداره المحتوى وبالتالي يستطيع الكونجرس
وتستطيع وتستطيع المحاكم الامريكيه
والمحاكم الاوروبيه ايضا والدول التي
لديها قوانين متعلقه بهذا الشان تستطيع ان
تحاسب شبكات السوشيال ميديا ولكنها مقصره
في ذلك خلينا نضع جانب موضوع التشريعه
ولكن في شخصيه ماسك والانتقادات التي
طلتها استاذتهم وظيفه كذلك يطرح بانه لا
ينت- لا يملك اراده همم محاوله همم رفع
مستوى تويتر او على الاقل عليه البعض يقول
بان نساء همم
ساءت هذه المنصه منذ تسلم
انا ما نتصور لانه هذه الشخصيه بالذات
الان ماسك يعني كان باداره تسلا تسلا هي
السيارات
على الكهرباء على البطاريات بقى الشعب
الامريكي وخاصه اليسار الاميركي كان سعيد
جدا لانه هو طبعا يميل الى
التغيير المناخي واستعمال السيارات
الصواريخ كمان كان سعيد جدا
ومن القاهره احمد الشيخ مستشار طرق مايه
شكرا جزيلا لكم
والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]